can you believe it we're just a few
weeks away from the first day of class
in clark county
and as thousands of students head back
to school eight news now
we are helping them get ready with what
they need to succeed
bianca holman live this morning with how
you can take part in our school supply
drive which starts bianca today you've
got some supplies yourself it looks like
yes for sure john we've got our
backpacks time to grab them
and of course stuff them with all the
things that you need and soon enough
there'll be kids walking into this
elementary school here at james mcmillan
and we are here to help those students
that need those school supplies so we do
have a school supply drive that starts
today
so here's some more details about how
you can help many families hit hard by
the pandemic and many still unemployed
so
trying to fund school supplies may be
difficult we've partnered up with smith
to collect
school supplies for our community we
want to provide kids with the tools they
need to of course be successful this
year
so starting today until july 29 supplies
collected will benefit the teacher
exchange we're collecting things like
backpacks folders colored pencils clorox
wipes and you can drop all those items
off at smith stores across the valley
from henderson to north las vegas and of
course right here
in las vegas and coming up in the next
half hour i'm going to talk about
immunizations and all that you need to
know about preparing
your child to get the shots that they
need and of course possibly the copen 19
vaccine if they're old enough and those
details are coming up in the next half
hour reporting live from near 10a in
lake mead bianca holmen 8 news now your
abc's bianca thank you very much getting
kids ready for school